ich glaube ich muss einfach mal ein
bisschen niemand an die ganze sache
sondern mein name ist luca und herzlich
willkommen hier heute zu einem neuen
video auf meinem kanal ihr seht bereits
im titel und zwar spiele ich heute ein
psycho horror spiel und für jede
situation in der ich angst habe habe ich
mir extra seine maske vorbereitet dass
spieler die ich mal angefangen ich bin
mir jetzt schon in die hose
[Musik]
ich hab keine ahnung was ich hier gerade
machen soll
[Musik]
das ist ich sehe da ist irgendwas auf
dem boden ein tennisball okay das spiel
ganz kurz vor euch zur erklärung soll
auch so eine ähnliche simulation
simulation sein
ich
was ist das das ist ein lautsprecher das
ist mein pistor wahrscheinlich also
jeder hat ja in seiner wohnung so ein
kleines roller waren wo man halt mal
rein test klar ich habe keine ahnung was
ich jetzt genau hier machen soll
das spiel wurde mir vorgeschlagen hab
ich aus versehen auf chinesisch
eingestellt ich glaube das spiel ist
einfach auf chinesisch aber wir haben
hier englische wörter setzungen okay ich
stelle mich mal hierhin genau dem rules
letzte gehen ich kenne keine regeln 1
4005 red bull and world als ich soll den
ball nehmen und werfen
ich fühle mich hier grad ein bisschen
unwohl aber gut gehen wir mal zu den
ball hin
ich drücke die taste gedrückt ok ich
muss gedrückt halten
block and return to the center okay das
ist mein sleeping blog
dann gucke ich krieche keks
das spiele ich hier
also ich soll wohl meinen ball jetzt
hinnehmen von meinem komischen schlaf
dingsbums wer auch immer da schlafen
will und jetzt sollte ich den ball noch
da werfen
er lächelt naja ich hab halt keinen korb
[Musik]
ich habe leicht angst vor diesem loch so
lässt sich das spiel schon viel besser
spielen also ich soll jetzt wohl den
ball nehmen und soll den nach dort
schmeißen
do you feel your body dass sich lesen
dicke springt auf deutsch also die
nächste frage do you feel contained ich
habe keine ahnung was content bedeutet
ich habe auch angst vor diesem loch da
was ist wenn ich den ball da mal rein
werfe
nö
einfach wieder raus ich habe extrem
angst vor diesem loch freunde ich weiß
nicht was da passiert die musik macht
mich auch so ein bisschen kehre ich mir
jetzt mal nach links
ich habe keine ahnung was ich hier
beantworten soll
ich habe keine ahnung studio stehe also
fürchte ich mich ohne einen körper
scheiß auf den körper ich fürchte mich
gerade so oder so wie access oder partie
also existiere ich ohne einen körper ich
würde mal sagen ja oder also schon bald
wieder nach dort ich weiß nicht ob es
richtig oder falsch gehört
[Musik]
ein wenig den raum damit ihr simulation
was weiß ich bruder ist dass die
abiturprüfung oder was ich schaue mich
jetzt noch mal ein bisschen in diesem
raum hier um hier ist halt mein bett da
vorne ist das loch ich bin ick diese
scheiße doch wir haben aber gut okay das
war die frage ja okay danke also wir
gehen jetzt einfach wieder den ball und
ich schmeiße ihn wieder nach rechts
was ich bin weniger wert als ein keks
warum spielt er seine musik ich habe ein
bisschen schiss ich habe als kritisch da
passiert gleich was ich schwöre euch
warum spielt es gelingt ihm in der depot
vom feld zur wirtschaft
ich habe schiff
ich will mich da nicht umdrehen jetzt
kommen wieder alle hauptberuflichen
horror game spieler an und sagen so jan
er ist ja völlig schlimm luca spiel
passiert gar nichts
playback und während facing bewohnern
bereut nein mann ich selbstständig einen
play off the wall on the left facing the
wall und jonas los geht's los
was ist das
hallo
dann stehen ich glaube ich muss ein
bisschen die man an jeder die ganze
sache
morgens circles around the three times
turning to watch your left
will ich das machen
nein
werde ich das jetzt machen ja ich laufe
durch den raum bambara banja meinem
schönen bettchen er da ist das doch okay
noch ist da nichts was kann ich mit ich
kann noch schneller laufen auch okay ich
kann schiff gedrückt läuft dann häufig
ein bisschen schneller eine runde bin
ich schon gelaufen freunde ich habe
trotzdem komplett angst mich jetzt
wieder nach links zu drehen das ist so
eine prädestinierte aufgabe dafür dass
bei der letzten runde gleich da
irgendwas rausgeschossen kommt um mich
trifft meinen körper ich schwitze am
ganzen körper und stellen an denen immer
wusste dass das schweissdrüsen sind mein
gott die letzte runde jetzt du bleibst
da drin mein lieber nachbar alles cool
wir sind cool miteinander
wir sind cool tippte gerade ja schon zu
beginn mainball runtergeschmissen
konsumierten mitspielen cookie leute
mein herz rast schon wieder vielleicht
kann ich mir für nächstes horrorspiel
teil oder irgendwie so mancher impuls
gerät kaufen sondern digital ist dann
kann ich euch das einblenden share your
pussy
[Applaus]
nein
das sind alles prädestinierte aufgaben
dafür dass ich gleich getötet werde von
meinem nachbarn hier nimm
[Musik]
ich soll mich der 20 mal im kreis drehen
wird ziemlich komplett war 12 zweimal
dreimal viermal kann ich dass ich ganz
schnell drehen einfach noch ein bisschen
schnell erwartet wo bin ich jetzt 7
der typ ist schon ein bisschen schwung
recht dass mein bett und da ist das loch
mit einem chorischen affen bild meint
tennisball und meinem nachbarn der nicht
weiß wer ich bin ok nich entscheidungen
bringen will
kuki ich kann das gar nicht mehr
das ist eine ganz andere art horror
spiel als das das ich vor ein paar tagen
gespielt habe playboy what you never
verpiss dich ich beende die scheiße
jetzt ich bin alleine hier der wind also
dieser scheiß sabine sturm mit die ganze
zeit gegen meine fenster ich habe
einfach nur noch angst mein herz rast
ich schwitze am ganzen körper und spiele
hier gerade kein spiel von wegen oder
kommen zombies und schlachten 1 ab das
kann man sich alles geben aber das ist
psycho horror
ich habe euch einen link zu dem spiel
und in die beschreibung gepackt die
entwickler des spiels selbst beschreiben
das spiel auch als psychological horror
experience wenn ihr wollt dass ich mich
in einem neuen video in ein paar tagen
an der stelle weiter spiele dann schafft
90.000 likes das werdet ihr nicht
hinkriegen
hoffe ich